want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know
you've got something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from louise hay
enjoy
i know that you've heard me say many
times or you've read or
listened on the tapes that loving
yourself is the most powerful thing we
can do
then everything flows everything flows
beautifully
now i'm not talking about vanity or
arrogance because that is not love
that's always
fear i'm talking about just really
respecting and appreciating this
incredible
magnificent being that we are
you know little babies know how to love
themselves
you were born in pure love all of you
there's not
one little baby alive i that i know of
that
ever criticizes its body or ever says
my hips are too big you ever heard a
baby say that
they're just thrilled and delighted that
they have a body
and they rejoice in it and they love
themselves they love their toes they
love everything about themselves
they absolutely adore they express their
feelings
you know when a baby is happy you know
it when a baby is angry the whole
neighborhood knows it they're never
scared to let people know
how they feel they live in the moment
and they're filled with courage
and they're wonderful and we were all
like that
got to remember that you were filled
with courage and you were full of love
and you adored yourself when you were
very little
the simple part that most people don't
understand
is that every thought we think in every
word we speak
is creating our future it's as though
our thoughts
go out into the universe and are
accepted
and brought back to us as experience
now that is a very simple thing but most
people don't get it they don't
understand it they've never heard it
before and they think it's ridiculous
but if you can really accept the fact
that every time you think a thought
and every time you speak a word you are
literally
painting your future making your dinner
whatever you want to call it you are
creating
and you're creating your own life
and this is simple but it's not
easy to accept but once you accept it
then you can start deliberately creating
what you want in your life
and you begin to be aware of what you
don't want in your life and how you are
contributing to it
now i think this has been around forever
but for some reason
in the last 20 years the universe has
wanted
this to go out among all the people or
all the people that are ready for it
see most of us just think they think
think think think think and we don't pay
any attention to what we're thinking
we're just doing it but that's something
you need to train yourself to do
to begin to train yourself to be aware
of what you're thinking
and and one of the ways to do that is to
periodically say to yourself what am i
thinking
would i like this thought to create my
life
would i like to have the experience that
this thought could bring to me
now it takes a while to do that but even
if we can begin on the smallest level
to be aware of our thinking we can start
to make changes
i think that everything you think and
everything you speak
goes out from you into the universe and
comes back to you
multiplied uh it's almost as though the
universe is
listening to everything you say and
everything you think and saying oh
that's what they want
but most of the time we're talking very
negatively about ourselves we talk about
how awful we are
we're not good enough we can't get this
we can't get that how can the universe
bring you anything good if that's the
way you're talking
also if you want to have more
self-confidence and self-belief
i've created a special free program
called 254
because the sign says that it takes up
to 254 days of consecutive action to
build a habit
so what i'm going to do is send you an
unlisted video to your email
every day for 254 days for free
to help your confidence and self-belief
shift forward
the link to join is in the description
below i think that everything you
think and everything you speak goes out
from you into the universe
and comes back to you multiplied
loving yourself is the most powerful
thing we can do
what good is a nice car if you are full
of resentment all the time
what you're saying is the quality of
life doesn't mean a really nice house
or a really nice car but it doesn't have
to but what good
is a nice car if you are full of
resentment
all the time and you drive around hating
everybody
that's not going to help anything it's
much better if you had an old car
and you were grateful and appreciative
of life
when i work with people when i workshops
or classes or anything i always try to
get people just to open their arms so
that we can let the new and remember
this is the subconscious mind and this
is where we're holding
so this is saying nothing new will get
in so i always like to feel
that i'm open and receptive to new ideas
and i'm willing to learn and i'm willing
to change and i'm willing to grow
and sometimes i don't want to and
sometimes it hits
areas that i don't really care to change
at the moment
and you know that's always an area that
i know is important for me to work on
to me i think enlightenment is letting
go
of all the things we believe that are
not
benefiting us us in life or the barriers
to
our life to the good things in life and
to release them one by one and to
think i don't have to believe that
anymore
or do i want to believe that anymore and
making a conscious
choice when we can understand that every
single thing we believe
has been a choice and it
may or may not be true it can be true
for you and not for you
because it's your belief system and your
belief system and then i have my belief
system
i say a lot that may be true for you
it's not true for me i may not say that
out loud
but people are doing things they're
saying things and i think that to myself
a lot
and also it has nothing to do with me
whatever's going that has nothing to do
with me because i'm
under the law of my own consciousness
this is my pathway and you have your
pathway you have yours everybody does
so we're all on a journey and i think
the more conscientious we are about it
and the more conscious choices we make
the better our journey is or the easier
or the swifter or that we get more
goodies or
we have better health i think that's
important because we do have a tendency
in
in the society to just want to be fixed
right
and that's it and that's it when i get
over this problem
this will be it i'll never have to deal
with anything you know a lot of us just
want to stop
when we hit a safe place yeah i mean
you've got a bit of money you've got
some nice friends you have a good house
to live and you're okay
you know and you think all right that's
fine i'm not going to touch
anything else but i have watched me and
how life
works for me is that when i get to a
really good level
then it's like okay now we're going to
deal with this thing yeah
and there's another thing and i've
learned to just say okay what do i do
yeah
you know instead of leave me alone don't
talk to me about that
i say thank you many many many times of
the day
often not to anyone else i just you know
oh thank you that's so
wonderful thank you and it's uh
you know you find more and more things
to be thankful about we were i was
driving up today from
san diego and the wildflowers
on the hillsides are just beautiful this
year
and i was thinking i was so glad that i
had the opportunity to see them
because if i stayed down there i
wouldn't have with this drive which was
you know not a drive i particularly
wanted to make but it was gorgeous
i think it really starts with realizing
that you don't love yourself
that most people don't most people feel
they're not good enough they haven't
done it right they won't do it right
they'll never be enough
and they're definitely not lovable and
when we
come from that space it's very hard to
create things for ourselves that are
really good
so in the early days when i worked with
people i used to
fix this problem and fix that problem
and you'd have this a health thing and
we'd work on that and we'd work on this
and one day i discovered much to my
amazement
that if i would help people learn to
love themselves to really accept
themselves as they are
we didn't have to work around problems
because it was almost like a miracle
everything seemed to fall away it's a
hard one for people because we're
we grow up believing that we're not good
enough and
nothing is right i remember
lots of times i would ask people well
what is really wrong with you what have
you done that is so
terrible that you're not acceptable to
yourself and i never ever ever got an
answer that made any sense
you know they might say something like
well i'm too fat well
so you know
but i when you talk about
loving yourself a lot of people think
that that's vanity
but it isn't really it has nothing to do
with that
that is narcissistic but to really
care for you and to acknowledge that you
are an important being it's almost like
in the bible they would say
uh you recognize that you are a child of
god that
therefore you are perfect but even if
you're not
a biblical person if you can recognize
that you
are a being that has self-worth if you
can really
recognize your own worth then you start
to treat yourself differently and i
think that's what's so
very important about loving yourself is
you stop
beating yourself up you stop making
yourself wrong you stop talking about
how awful you are
and you stop saying things like i'm
really stupid and stuff
and you start to treat yourself with a
certain amount of respect
and this makes an enormous difference
because
what you give out in life is what comes
back to you
so if you're giving out a feeling of i'm
okay
i'm good enough as i am and i am
acceptable
and i love life and i love me and you
start having gratitude for yourself and
for life
then life treats you differently because
you are having a different
vibration that you're giving out and
getting back
and that's when things really start to
flow now a lot of people don't realize
it but you have to practice you just
have to start it
and that's why i try to get people to do
a lot of mirror work
if you look in the mirror just simple
things like looking in the mirror
in your own eyes and saying i love you i
really
really love you and it helps if you use
your name louise i
love you i really love you it gets to
that little child inside that has been
rejected for so
long and it breaks open sort of a dam or
a door
or whatever you want to call it and it's
like
little miracles start to happen lots of
little good
things happen and the universe
loves grateful people the more grateful
you are the more you get
to be grateful about people think that
prosperity is just
money but really there's many many other
things that come under this
auspices of prosperity you know you can
be very
poor in time if you feel really rushed
all the time and always pressured
you have poverty in your time but if you
feel that you have
all the time in the world and that
whatever you want to finish you'll get
done and it will
it will all happen then you're really
prosperous in time
and what about success you know if you
feel that it's really
way beyond your reach then you're never
going to get
it but if you feel that you can be
successful whatever that means to you
then that's wonderful that's prosperity
wisdom
do you have prosperity and wisdom do you
feel that all the wisdom in the universe
is available to you
or do you think oh i'm just me and i
don't know very much
and you know i can't figure things out
if you feel that you're really connected
with the universe and you really trust
that part of you
that's inside then you can be absolutely
prosperous in the abundance
of wisdom and what about love
do you feel that you have an abundance
of love
or are you very poor in love is there
very just a little bit of it in your
life
how about joy do you feel you're really
prosperous and i have an abundance of
joy
or is that something you just allow
yourself a little bit of now and then
and you really are very poor in joy and
then what about
beauty do you see beauty everywhere
do you allow yourself to experience an
abundance of beauty
and of course there's money then there's
money too you know what do you let
yourself have
i like to use that uh image a lot of the
ocean
standing in front of the ocean with a
container in your hand
you know and you're there and you have
this container but what
is it is it a thimble with a hole in it
is it a small cracked cup is it a mug
is it a vase but no matter how much you
have whatever your container it is
and no matter how much you're taking
from the ocean of life
and even though we're all standing there
we're not robbing each other
and there's plenty for everyone and no
matter how much we take
there is no way we're gonna run that
ocean right
and if you can see yourself standing at
the ocean of life
in the same way and remember the
container that you have
is your consciousness and you can always
change your consciousness and it doesn't
matter if you came from poverty
it doesn't matter where you came from
and it doesn't even matter
what your parents beliefs were because
it's your consciousness
and what you're choosing to think about
prosperity and your ability to deserve
it
is what's going to create it for you a
lot of people say i don't want to look
at the past my childhood was miserable
and i never want to think about it again
well then it's very important that you
start forgiving
because forgiveness sort of wipes the
slate clearly
so that other things can come in yeah
yeah well the tapping
setup phrase right is even though i have
whatever the problem is
i love and forgive myself i accept
myself
to me like the mirror work that i do
we'll have people do it also
is to look in the mirror and look into
your own eyes and start with something
really simple but difficult like i love
you i
really really love you and most people
can't do that at all because it's just
too painful yeah they have all these
messages back here that says you're no
good and you can't be in
beside you your makeup isn't on right or
you forgot to shave today or something
you know
but once you can do that if you do it
over and over again for a while
it's like you connect on a different
level with that inner child
who's been waiting for years and years
and years for you to acknowledge it
and something happens and i couldn't
tell you what it is
but i have learned that the people who
do their affirmations in front of a
mirror
make much quicker progress than other
people yeah i guess
it just it pushes through when life
calls
us that's when we have to answer
people say how did you do everything
that you did
well i answered the telephone and opened
the mail
and did was it what was in front of me
and then life would give me something
else to do and something else to do
and it's interesting because it's now
been i think 25 years since i wrote the
second book you can heal your life
and in that period of time
i that book alone has sold
40 million copies worldwide
[Music]
and i feel i've always felt that i
didn't do anything
to promote it at all it's just life took
over and life said this book is going to
go to this country and this book is
going to go to this country
and go to this country and it's gone
many many places all over the world i
even have
two chinese versions there's the chinese
version of
traditional china and then there's the
chinese version of the taiwan which is
the new china
you never know where life is going to
take your work
and i think that it's important that you
don't go into it to say how much money
can i make oh i'm going to be rich i've
got to do this
because books don't make you that rich
but what they do is open the world to
you
and my thought has always been how can i
help the people
how can i help the people and i think if
you come from that point of view
it becomes a lot easier if it is true
that your thoughts
shape your life would you want what you
were just thinking right now to become
true for you
if it's a thought of worry or anger or
hurt
or revenge or fear how do you think this
thought will come back to you
if you hear yourself expressing negative
words
of any sort stop in mid-sentence
either rephrase the sentence or just
drop it
you could even say to it out you get to
choose any and all thoughts you wish
these thoughts create your future
experiences
let us stay away from thoughts that
create
problems and pain some of you know my
little blue book and the fact that i've
been doing a lot of work with dis-ease
for a long time and for every part of
the body
there is a mental pattern and for every
dis
ease in the body there is a mental
pattern and when you know what they are
you can begin to change the mental
patterns so that
you can change the dis-ease you see we
don't want to be sick
no that's a blanket statement sometimes
people do want to be sick because it's a
good way to get out of something
the rest of us know how to say no if you
don't know how to say no you may have to
create an illness in order to say no
because that's we've made in society
we've made that a legitimate way of of
getting out of things
but basically we do not want to be ill
and yet we need
every dis ease that we have because it
is the body's way
of telling us that there is a false idea
in consciousness
something that we're doing something
that we're believing something that
we're saying
is not for our highest good
and the body is saying please
and it's sort of almost like tugging
saying pay attention
[Music]
so
when we know what these patterns are it
gives us
again a choice of whether we wish to do
something about it or not
there are lots of things you can do to
help you become more conscious
of what is going on and because so many
of our belief systems really
are unconscious or subconscious we're
not aware of them
they're just things that were bred into
us as we were children
uh is to take a little time to figure
out what they are
and i always say a really good exercise
is to take a big sheet of paper and
write
on top of it say what i think about men
and then another one what i think about
women what do i think about
money what do i think about any subject
you can think of
and just write all the things that come
down come out
of your thoughts and whether they sound
good or not just
write them down and
[Music]
any one subject if you just write them
all down and then look at them and see
how many are positive and how many are
negative
and if you can take those negative ones
and turn them around
make them into positive affirmations
then you can start
clearing up what you believe about say
money that is not positive for you
and or is keeping you from bringing
money in
and and you can do that with lots of
things in your life so you can really
begin to realize what you do believe
about these things
so you can't change your thoughts if you
don't know what your thoughts are
there is a law of thinking and we are
beginning to learn about it and it is
like a computer if you have this
gorgeous computer put in front of you
and you don't know what to do with it
it's a piece of
junk but if you learn the language of
the computer
miracles happen
and that is what the law of thinking is
when you learn how it works
miracles happen what you think
and what you believe is what will come
true for you
your thoughts create your life
it's that simple and when we can get
that
we can make enormous changes gratitude
works a lot
if just being grateful for everything
the more
i always say the universe loves
gratitude the more you're grateful
for what the good is in your life the
more good you get to be grateful about
and it's it's like you know if somebody
gives you a present or gives me a
present and i say oh my god i hate that
color and it doesn't fit and you know
that person will never give me another
present
but if you say oh it's wonderful and
thank you i really adore it it's great
that person is probably going to want to
buy you a present every time they see
something they think you would like
and it's like that with the universe the
universe loves
gratitude for those of people that have
tried to change their thinking but seem
to be
stuck and can you give them some advice
to help them to be more positive or to
get through well i don't think that
they've been trying and they're stuck
i think they just haven't tried because
if you will practice this
even a small amount it makes a
difference
i have a simple exercise i give
everybody and some people say oh that's
so stupid it's so silly
but i ask them to look in the mirror
especially first thing in the morning
and just look in their eyes and say
their name
and say i love you i really really love
you
and this is enormously hard for most
people to do to begin with
but as you continue to do it it makes a
big difference
you see life loves you life really loves
you
but if you don't love yourself it's very
hard for life to bring you the goodies
because you've got this wall up so when
you can learn to love who you
are and that's the way you were born
when you were a little tiny baby and
when i say you i mean everybody
listening to this
we all adored ourselves we loved our
bodies we loved every part of ourselves
and then we started to listen to other
people who told us we weren't good
enough or we didn't do it right
or no no no and so we decided that maybe
we weren't very good
and that's where we get all mixed up but
when we can get back to that point of
just
adoring this marvelous critter in here
then life says oh they've she's got it
she's got it let's give her goodies
and then the next step is to be very
grateful about it
yes when you're really grateful then
they want to give you more
one of the things that i think about the
work that i do and the work our company
does
is that every product that we sell or
that probably
that you get as a gift from us uh
has the possibility to change the
quality of your life to improve the
quality of your life now whether you
actually take that opportunity or not is
up to you that's freedom
but you have everything we give out can
help people
really improve the quality of their
lives when we have a problem
most of us go oh panic panic god what
are we going to do
but i have something that i try to get
people to say
when the minute there's a problem you
stop and you go all is well
all is well everything's working out for
my highest good
and out of this experience only good
will come
and i am safe and you do this
if it's a small thing i say it two or
three times if it's a bigger issue i
babble it incessantly
but all is well everything is working
out for my highest good
out of this situation only good will
come
and i am safe now this gives
this quiets your inner turmoil down
long enough for the universe to find the
solution to the so-called problem
see when there's problems we don't have
to fix problems so much we need to fix
our thinking
and our attitude about how we respond to
them
and then you get less and less and when
when the solution comes you say thank
you
if you have very strong beliefs within
you
that you don't deserve good things in
your life
and a lot of people have that then there
can be delays
and sometimes people say well
affirmations don't work i've done
them but when they're doing for instance
prosperity affirmations
and they've done some prosperity
affirmations and they say it doesn't
work nothing's happening and i say well
all right
how many prosperity affirmations did you
do in a day
and they'll say three probably and they
say all right how many
poverty affirmations did you do this day
and that could be 300 depending on where
you're coming from
and what are is running through your
mind
see i have this one of my thoughts about
life is that only good
lies before me and i've been saying this
for
many years so it doesn't really matter
to me
what happens in life because i know it's
going to be good
remember little tiny babies when they're
born
they absolutely adore themselves and
they're
totally open and they're full of love
[Music]
they express themselves freely they ask
for what they want
they love their bodies from the top of
the toe to the top of their head to the
tip of their toes
and every point in between including
their own feces which they'll gladly rub
all over their bodies because nobody's
taught them guilt and shame
they know how wonderful they are and
then somewhere along the line we get
this idea
that we're not good enough and we start
putting our tape
tape measures around our waistline to
tell us if we're acceptable
or we read magazines that say we have to
be a certain height or a certain weight
before we're acceptable
or we listen to the media that says we
have to use a certain deodorant before
we're acceptable
you know it just doesn't make sense
we are absolutely divine magnificent
expressions of life
all of us and like when we were in the
circle looking at each other
we each face is another unique
expression of god
and we're not supposed to be alike since
time began on this planet there have not
been
two snowflakes alike and there's
certainly not been two people alike
and we're always trying to be like
everybody else so we're acceptable
our uniqueness is what makes us
wonderful
so we want to love that and cherish it
and acknowledge it
you see if we really believe in our
uniqueness
and the wonder of each being then there
is no competition
and no comparison there can't be we're
just
different and we're meant to be
different and that's wonderful
i think we get we all get certain ahas
and that's when we sort of learn
something we say oh
okay and then if we can keep that
what we've learned and practice it then
we've made another step and we can move
forward
um yes it's a lifetime journey and we
never stop learning i'm 80
and i'm still learning
though the lessons are easier now than
they used to be
i like to think of that when we start we
have all these boulders in front of us
on our pathway
and we start to get the boulders out of
the way and you finally get to the point
where it's
gravel and gravel you can handle
you know and you can sweep gravel and
you can do things
so and then occasionally there's an old
boulder
that rolls back into your bag
you think oh i thought i i thought i had
that one
but not completely and
you know also i think that when we learn
lessons we think oh i've learned that
one it'll never happen again i've done
that and
that's it well how do you know you've
done it
unless it comes by once more and see how
you react
have you really learned it is it really
nothing for you
have you gone beyond that or are you
going to go right back into the same old
reaction
see we're never wrong that's what we
need to learn that we
always doing the best we can with the
understanding and awareness and
knowledge we have
at that moment if you're in a job you
don't like if you're in a relationship
you don't like if you're in a
a house you don't like and you want
something new begin to
bless with love interesting
bless with love where you are
and and know that you're releasing your
current situation with love
if it's a job release it with love to
the next person who will be delighted to
have it
if it's an apartment do the same thing
if it's a relationship
release that person with love to
happiness
which is meaningful to them
and that leaves you free to create and
accept happiness that is meaningful to
you
stop scaring yourself
how often do you terrorize yourself
with your own thoughts you get into
absolute
terror and it's only coming from your
thoughts nobody out there is doing a
thing
sometimes it's an old family pattern
sometimes we get new things
i would like people to when you have
time to make a list of your fears
make a list of your fears and then give
yourself the opportunity
to turn each fear into a positive
affirmation
turn each one into something positive
and remember
always you are in charge you are always
in charge
see one idle thought doesn't make
a whole lot of difference thoughts are
like drops of water
you drop a drop of water and it doesn't
mean much
but if you keep dropping and keep
dropping you get a puddle on the floor
and then you can get a little pond and a
lake
and finally you can create an ocean and
with our own
thoughts we can drown in a sea of
negativity
or we can float on the ocean of life
and it's up to us the thoughts we
think accumulate and what sort of
puddles are you standing in
or are you up to here or are you up to
here and trying to paddle
now what are you doing to yourself when
we're willing to change
our thinking we can change our
experiences
and it doesn't matter if you've got a
big
puddle of negative thoughts you know you
can move over here and create a puddle
of
mindfulness positive thoughts you can
make changes always
so you want to turn those fear thoughts
into positive affirmations
let them work for you see i have a thing
when i was
seeing people that i got to the point
where i would not see
anyone who did not make their own
appointment
i have found occasionally people have
sent people to me as a present
oh you must go see louise here i'll give
it to you as a present every one of
those has turned out to be a disaster
half the time the people didn't turn up
when they did turn up they weren't
really interested
when they seemed to be interested they
never went away and did anything or if
they did it was a little bit
and they never came back we have to be
ready to do it
ourselves remember each person has come
to this planet to learn a lesson
you have your lessons you have your
lessons i have my lessons you have your
lessons they're all different
we cannot learn the other person's
lessons we are not here to change other
people
we are here to change ourself that is
what we've come to the planet for to
change ourself
if we try to do it for someone else
or learn their lesson or make it nice
they don't get to learn it and even if
we fix it
isn't it amazing how they turn around
and recreate it again
and we all know people like that we've
paid their rent
or we've gotten them out of some mess or
we've done this for them or that for
and two months later they're in the same
problem because it's their pattern
it has nothing to do teaching them how
to get out of it it is much better if
they're willing to learn
so it's like you know the student must
come to the teacher
and when the student is ready the
teacher is there always
i want you to say to yourself your name
i love you i really really love you
i love you i really
really love you it's a new thing you
probably haven't done it before
but what we're really trying to do is to
connect with the inner child within
who has been neglected for so very long
most of us when we look in a mirror we
criticize ourselves
we make fun of ourselves we say
derogatory things to ourselves it's a
habit
and what we want you to do is to start
connecting with that inner child within
you that
wants so much to be loved
and hasn't been for perhaps years and
years and years and years
and maybe never when it was a child
i know this is a tough one to stay but
if it's too tough to start
with you can start with something like
louise i'm willing to learn to like you
not quite so threatening
so i want you to this is something i
want you to do
a lot first thing in the morning i want
you to get in the habit of
having your little mirror with you
whipping it out at any time
or anytime you pass a mirror say
something nice to yourself
i i will look at myself and say you look
fantastic
kid and sometimes i'll say you know you
may not be as tight and taught as you
used to be
but you're fabulous you're absolutely
wonderful
we want to be our own cheerleader we
want the things that we say to ourselves
support us and love us and make us feel
good or make us feel
silly you know you're a hot potato
and it's not only just saying you love
yourself but do your affirmations into
in front of the mirror do forgiveness in
front of a mirror if you have somebody
you need to forgive
do it in front of a mirror and have get
yourself
if you have a big mirror sit down in
front of it
because you won't run away you can't
it's too hard to get up
and you can sit there and you can cry
but you'll go through it whatever it is
and it'll be fast the mirror as small as
this may be can really help you connect
with yourself looking in the mirror and
saying how can i make you happy what can
i do to make you
happy today now i've got a special bonus
clip that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action
for the next week when you watch a video
and you just get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
got to take action
but when you get motivated and then you
create a specific plan of action for
when and how you're going to do it your
number jumps from 35
to 91 percent chance of following
through and when you commit to somebody
else
like posting down here in the comments
below that number jumps to 95 percent
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so you
can follow through and i can celebrate
you every single thought we have or
every sentence we speak is an
affirmation and it's either positive or
negative
and it's going out from us and it's
creating our experiences
however when we talk about doing
affirmations what we're talking about
is making definite
positive statements to create something
in our life or to remove
something in our life you see if you
stand there and say
i don't want this job or i don't want
this relationship or i don't want these
hips or i don't want whatever
that does not get you what you want
that's
what i call fighting the negative and it
doesn't do anything
but keep what you have that you say you
don't want
however if you start saying and doing
affirmations that i
have a wonderful new job or i have this
most
absolutely marvelous relationship then
you're beginning
to create what it is you do want
affirmations are like planting
seeds and if you think for a moment when
you put a seed in the ground you do not
get instant tomato plant or instant
strawberries or instant oak tree
that seed goes in the ground and it has
to germinate
that's the first thing which means it
breaks open its little shell
and little roots begin to go down and it
gets nourishment from the earth
and only then does the first little
shoot come up through the ground
now when we're doing affirmations too
often people say well that isn't a
million dollars and they
stomp on that first little chute they
don't give it a chance to grow
[Laughter]
doing affirmations is like planting a
seed in the ground
and watering is it it is like repeating
your affirmations
and you just keep doing them and you
keep doing them and you keep doing them
and it doesn't matter whether you see
the results or you don't see the results
and sometimes it just takes time
and too many people will do affirmations
for two or three days and say see
doesn't work you know
if everything happens in the perfect
time
space sequence and we want to trust that
and we want to know that
so if you begin to do affirmations for
yourself
and i think it's important that we do
that on a daily basis
decide what you want and begin to do
positive statements in present tense for
what you want
you never want to say i will have or i'm
going to have because if you do that it
keeps it in the future
and remember if you say i have a
wonderful new apartment
and you're living in a dump it doesn't
mean that this is not a true statement
it means you are
planting the seed that will germinate
and grow and become the new apartment
so you just keep doing it no matter what
where you are
if you want some incredible mel robbins
motivation check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe i'll see you there
at some point
you're going to have the courage at some
point you're going to have the
confidence and it's total
frankly i don't are we allowed to swear
okay um
it's it's complete garbage and so there
are so many people